all right so today i wanted to emphasize
somebody who
i have to say
i thought everybody knew
i mean okay maybe if you're an amateur
chess player you have no reason to know
this person but i was talking to my st
louis university chess team
you know full of grand masters and
international masters and supposedly
they read books
and they had no idea who eingorn was
and and and i see that i see the the
four people here and they're like einger
who on earth is that guy
and we're going to be talking about
varus ironborn today
where is lafayette yes
uh he is still a grandmaster he's an
active not not really an active player
he he peaked
in the early
90s late 80s mostly late 80s
and he was really really good
he was so good he uh he got third in one
of the soviet chess championships
he was so good that at some point
uh he was a top 12 player
so he was
he was a really really big deal in the
chess world um
but he was never the level of some of
his contemporaries he was never
challenging gary he was never never
really challenging karpov he was never
really challenging you know the top dogs
in today's day like who would compare
him to
something like
you know paco vallejo tomaszewski
you know he's not a geary where you like
see him in every tournament and
everybody knows about him
he's one of those top 20 top 30 players
that
had some really cool games had a lot of
good results he uh won a gold medal
for the ukrainian team in the 2001 world
team championship he uh
was part of the ukrainian chess team in
three different olympiads one of them he
obtained a bronze
individually
uh so he was really good
let us
uh take a quick look at who he was as a
chess player
hila had a very varied style he was kind
of a fighter he was one of those players
that he liked some setups
um somebody somebody on chat asked me if
i could compare him to geary not really
i mean gary definitely is a more
accomplished chess player than even at
his young age
than what iron
uh ever managed to be i think gary
gary's top uh
ranking i think was second in the world
maybe third
you know definitely very very high ivo
was great but he was you know top 20 top
12 at his peak not not really pushing
for those candidate spots
uh he was one of those players that for
example played the grand prix but you
don't give them an amazing chance to
make it out of uh out of the grand prix
you know maybe uh maybe once in a while
he could potentially but he never did
so we're gonna take about a look at a
couple of his games
and more or less how he won some some
things and we're going to start with
this one i'm going to just uh
go ahead and skip through
the opening phase this is not very
important this is just in an open
tournament he's playing jakob zilberman
is a 2460 player uh this is in 1994
and in 1994 we we played chess a little
bit differently
than we play chess now i mean chess has
evolved chess is stronger we understand
a lot of things more
animation definitely not an inbound
trick definitely not an event no no
a different level actually i would be
surprised if somebody can come up with a
name to compare him with
he's very strong but not not the level
of somebody that pops to your head
and
we're gonna we're gonna just skip ahead
on this game
and we're gonna start right around
here
so
a lot of things happened and we don't
really care about it but we're going to
analyze this position as we always
analyze positions uh we're going to
start with
the strategic elements of the position
where our plans are i know this yada
yada i'm going is white silverman is
black it's white to play uh but let's
start
you can you can answer on chat you can
answer here on the
on the live audience as well what are
some of the things that we look at
when we make plans in a in a game of
chess
yeah there's a broad hanging so overall
the pawn structure in general uh not
just if it's hanging but in general the
pawn structure is something that we look
at
the pawn structure is something that
determines our strategy i say this a lot
in the lectures that i give here at the
club because it just is and sometimes we
skip over that because grandmasters are
so used to immediately going into the
pawn structure dissecting it and
forgetting about it in half a second
that we don't really talk about it very
much but the pawn structure is the soul
of the game if you don't have a good
knowledge of the position then you have
to look at the pawn structure first
what are some of the elements that we
can see the pawn structure is telling us
about the game
anybody can answer otherwise i'll just
absolutely white has more space why the
pawn structure
we have uh
let me make sure that this can i can
draw arrows
oh
it doesn't let me draw arrows normally
draws i like
can i do this
aha now i can draw errors perfect all
right
so
there are these three pawns that gave us
a clear spatial advantage
h4 and f4 are controlling a lot of space
on the king side
this pawn on d5
is giving us a huge space advantage in
the center
because it's restricting black structure
it's restricting the structure of the
pawns
and in some ways the knights yes it is a
vulnerability
in a sense right it's an isolated pawn
it's an isolated pawn because there is
no pawn next to it that where adjacent
to it that can can defend it so it's
already under a lot of pressure and i
don't have sex knight on b6 queen on b5
um
but for now it's dependent so i don't
have to worry about it
now do i have an advantage on the queen
side
that's white
yeah not really i am behind on the queen
side i don't have a lot of pieces there
my pawn structure doesn't really
indicate that i'm doing very well there
my only saving grace
is that this bishop on h3 is really
annoying this bishop on h3 is really
annoying because the rook cannot go to
c8
and start some kind of play there so
i think i'm not really better on the
queen side and yeah the center space is
really nice
so where where do i play
where does white play in this position
the king side yes everything indicates
that we should play on the king side in
this position
the paw structure is there the knight on
e3 is very powerful
this knight is great
it's doing a good job controlling the
queensland but also supporting brakes
on on that side of the board now since
we know that we're going on the king
side how are we doing this is going to
be a piece attack or a pawn storm
foster we're halfway there
we're halfway there our pawns are
already on f4 and h4 it means that we
can play f5 we can play h5 and start
trying to get at black's king
now
this is all well said and done it's nice
to have the strategy down i think we now
know which side both players are going
black needs to be careful he needs to
not die on the king's side while he
creates counter play on the queen side
he's not gonna be able to use his rook
because of our bishop
but
he can use this queen and can use his
knight and it can be quite annoying
um so now we can go at specific moves uh
chad suggested the movie rook d2 i don't
think it's a terrible move but this
knight on b6
to me
is not a good piece the only thing it
does is pressure this pawn
it would rather jump to c4 or even a4
and c5
although honestly if i put my rook there
i'm thinking let's trade off this pair
of knights that will ease the eventual
attack on the king side
and i will be good to go
so
instead of that let's go
i'm gonna play with b3 which makes a lot
of sense you defend the pawn first
and you don't allow
uh the trait of the knights on c4 so we
start with step one
and black says or i don't play queen a5
and keep hitting your pawns so that you
don't have time to pawn stormy
and
with the advance of computers and as an
asterisk going into some of these games
um
people learned how to defend much better
but there was still something to be
admired
about the ruthlessness of some of these
old old-school players in the 80s and 80
especially inspired by kasparov
on their attacks
where i think nowadays a lot of
grandmasters would just look at the
position say well i really need to
defend this pawn it is hanging i i
cannot really play queen e2 because
knight takes d5 is in the air
uh rogue d2 is not playable because i'm
hanging the rook so i will just play a4
and defend the pawn and the game goes on
but i'm going he wasn't interested in
that he was not about that jam of of
defending stuff
that f5 was suggested in the chat and i
think that's a good move
it it's a very normal move
and i think that also a lot of
fantastically attacked
tuned grandmasters would do that f5 in
this position and then figure it out
actually i would play that in a bullet
game and then figure it out
but this is a classical game
wasn't having it he played g4
he said boom boom boom let's go i'm
gonna give you my queen side and you're
gonna figure it out
and
black has no choice but i got no choice
at this position this is the nice thing
about playing white right it's not like
white black can say no i'm gonna like
just stop you and the king's like no
there's no stopping wood
temporarily too so you could bring the
rook in on ca g5 knight fd7 covers but
it is a bit slow
because if you think about it the
purpose of the rook coming into the
queen side is to take the pawns but you
can already take the pawns it might as
well let us win munch punch munch
and queen takes a2 is not only correct
but was played in the game
now correctness is something that we're
not going to care about too much in this
game
uh but after g5 here here we're going to
talk about something else practicality
uh in chess like in many other video
games and i assume life well it's tough
to play under pressure
yeah it's it's probably true that after
queen takes b3 which is played in the
game
black is technically better i i run this
through an engine and the engine says
yeah obviously black's better what are
you talking about blocks up two pawns
and i can defend
like a machine because i'm a machine
but chess players don't really think
like that we miss a lot of things and
it's much easier to play on the attack
than it is to play on the defense
now this this is a very solid g i'm
playing it's a very solid i am i think i
think silverman eventually made gm but
i'm not sure about that
um sorry sorry if you're watching so i
think i think he made you
um
but i think there's a lot of uh of
players especially in the amateur level
that are afraid of giving out material
because that's the way we're taught how
to play chass
and the truth is that defending is hard
defending is hard in chess and it's it's
one of the last things that you learn
how to do well
uh i would say that even at my level
it is very noticeable
the level of difference between my
ability to defend the position and the
ability of geary or favi or magnus
where
they can just hunker down up a pawn and
say i'm up a pawn and i'm going to find
every perfect move until i beat you when
i'm up upon
but it's not easy over the board it's
very easy to get pressured and miss
things and even at that level they
missed things now imagine
uh you know 20 some years ago
uh how chess was how chess was viewed
and the capacity that these people had
right there was no engines to tell you
many defensive patterns that we know
nowadays there's no engines to tell you
that that attack never worked
so sometimes you just believed in it
and in this case we're just gonna
believe
now i do like the next move and this is
uh
this is in my opinion a very very casper
move
kirk kasparov
had
a lot of good ideas and openings and
attacks and something like that but if
you sit down
and you look at everyone
every single one of gary's attacks
he makes sure his king is in the perfect
spot
it might take him one move to put him in
the perfect spot but he'll do it
and i think king g2 is a very good
and i'm going to explain them they're
hard to find
but here you have a couple of issues
that's why the first one is that the
moment you play f5
you run into knight e5
you don't really want to do a deal with
this stuff
now
oops i don't want to do that
uh i cannot remove my knight because i'm
pinned
i definitely do not want to trade this
bishop
so how can i increase my pressure
without releasing the tension i have
this tension on the king side i don't
want to release it i don't know if i
want to play h6 or i want to take i'll
probably take but i'm not married to it
how do i increase my pressure here
and i think
there's a couple of ways to do it but
the most obvious one to me is to
transfer stuff to the age file
so i can start to visualize scenarios in
which real threats happen
and one scenario such is that if this
rip on it was on h1
and i can take on d7 knight takes d7 and
this queen runs onto h3
i hit the knight
and
i hit the h
file however for that to ever work
the k needs to move
and since black is not threatening
anything
and i want to see what he plays because
i want to just increase my pressure
why not throw in the move king g2
it was an excellent spot to do so and
actually uh black goes wrong almost
immediately uh he plays the move knight
c5 which is actually not not a bad move
at all
the knight is moved from
the the problems that it has on d7 and
it has an actual threat
we have been talking about this knight
on b6 being a bad piece
and unfortunately he is threatening
knight c4
trading this knight for this knight now
it wasn't available the previous move
because remember that this bishop is
hitting the knight so this knight is
tethered to this one i cannot move it
right now but this will create this move
creates the threat of knight c4 next
move so anger goes a little
a little wild play some of rook before
again we're not going to really worry
about objectivity here but rd4 is a good
move because
uh in the sense that it it keeps up the
spirit of the position
the rook is still able to transfer on
this on this row
i can play f5 rook f4 h4
and
it's it's difficult to attack the rook
it actually is uh very well placed on
the center black attacks at once but the
queen defends it on d1 again the main
purpose is to keep
black's knights out of the action i want
to control d3
i want to control e4 i want to control
c4 because these are the hops
the hops of the knights i'm going to
keep the knights at bay
and i want to bring my stuff to the king
side twitch asks do you believe kasparov
could be top 10 today with the strength
in his prime in his prime kasparov would
be top 10 today yes
um
and
black says all right enough of this
dancing
yeah if you're not gonna do anything on
the king side i'm gonna start creating
threats and this is the correct way to
play you need to start creating threats
at some point
i'm going forward
so a5 happens and finally we have the
move f5 trying to break open uh the king
side
and now if this knight was on d7 i
wouldn't have played this because of
knight e5 but it's not on d7 so good
time to play f5
silverman looks at the position and says
um i don't know what the threat of that
is
and plays the move a4
and i think that move a4
is very brave
but it's a mistake the thing is it's not
an easy mistake to find why it looks
like black has everything under control
if you take twice
which happened in the game i don't know
why i did it this this way around
because it took the other way around
if you take twice
it doesn't seem obvious
how white proceeds from this position
e6 is lovely if i got my bishop 36 it's
pretty nice
it is just a check
but even if it wasn't just a check
knight takes e6 is on top this 9 on c5
is doing a very good job defending the
square
i want to play queen h5
but
i can't
i want to play queen somewhere but it's
tethered to the rook
i want to use my knight but it doesn't
have any great squares even if i i just
don't know what to do
but i'm going to have seen this from
advance
i had a very specific idea
and i think this is a very cool attack
he started with bishop f5
which must have shocked
zilberman
now this doesn't take anything but it
creates a very strong threat
that's right
yeah it wants to win the spawn on g6 and
this pawn is the the soul of the defense
right
if this pawn falls
then black white just understood the
queen and more importantly look at this
cool rook
it's preventing
the queen from coming in
so
look at the essence of the position
silverman believed and sorry anger in
some ways believed in the power of his
pieces
because
black's pieces are on the queen side and
i'm attacking the king
therefore something's got to give
and in this case he's right
bishop f5 attacks g6
and if you take which it wasn't the case
if you take queen h5 pretty much
finishes the game
unfortunately for black
after the move queen takes d4 i'm gonna
put a couple other variations just to
explain but queen takes d4
runs into queen e8 chuck
and after king h7 g6
it doesn't actually matter which way the
king goes
it's gonna run into a fork
so here check i pick up the queen easy
peasy
if you don't pick up the the rook i am
threatening queen g6
so queenie is a threat but queen g6 is
also a threat followed by either queen
takes f5 or rook h4 and rookie chain
whatever at that point now i have a
million ways to win i'll figure out
which one
right g6 is also a thread everything
wins you cannot take on f5 you just
cannot take on f5
it's possible that black thought that
the move king g7 would save him
and i think about king g7 is pretty
clever
uh if the pawn on g6 disappears
then
i need somebody
to guard the h5 square
that makes a lot of sense
however i'm going to sit a little bit
further
and he took on g6 took on g6
and he played a move
that i think is so easy to underestimate
its power
because we're consistently looking at
the king side we're looking at the king
side and you start immediately analyzing
with rook h4
rook h4 preparing the move queen h5 um
with problems for black
the problem is that actually after rook
h4
rotate shade it's not so easy
uh to make progress because the queen is
defending this rook
but kind of has a bolt from the blue
as chad points out
the move queen b1
is actually super powerful
it's funny but the way that white has
arranged his pieces does not allow black
to interpose anything on the diagonal
if the king
takes forward
then rook g4 will be made very soon
if the king
goes this way then i'll force you to
take my phone queen h7 wins the game
and if king f7 will thank you for
inviting my queen right so that only
really leaves one move king g7
check
all right
king g8 now ein gordon uh master of
soviet chess uh ukrainian champion
always repeats moves
as they're told
and after king g840 he sits down and
finds the correct continuation i'll let
chad or the audience find the the maiden
in something that's in this position
what is the killing blow
but yes knight takes e7 check and if i
take
so 97 rook takes
queen g6
now let's say rook g7
the visualization exercise
queen eight very good that's a check
attacks the king king on h7
yep rick h final is mate let's put that
on the board so 97 check
rook takes queen g6 now if the king goes
this way
rook h4 right that just finishes this
one is the same thing rook f4 you have
to interpose the rook i think with the
queen it's made easy peasy now a little
harder but we solved it rogue g7
28 king h7
rook h4 and again checkmate
so instead silverman played 97 in panic
played king f8 but that only allowed the
very pretty finish
queen h7
which threatens checkmate in one knight
g6 is actually checkmate
uh and after rookie seven
queen h a check
this is made in one
two three four i think maybe a little
bit less but
one two actually it's just in two
king here
check and this is made in one and this
is also made in one
so
kind of a brilliant game in some ways
because the attack actually doesn't work
at all
if not for the move bishop f5 the move
bishop f5 is actually a key
to unlocking the king side
uh for white
and i think it's really cool
that
white just played like it doesn't care
right
give me click on my phones i don't care
i'm going to attack you on the king side
you will fall apart at some point
and i i think that nowadays players do a
little bit of defending
but honestly
sometimes you miss something and if you
miss something like bishop f5 what can
you do
i mean you miss it you miss it right
it's not it's not an easy move to play
but eingram was just an expert at trying
to find opportunities
all right so that was probably his most
famous game
i'm going to send it to another kind of
famous one
this one is a really really long game
and if i had to describe iron as a chess
player matt was a fighter
he liked balls
uh he eventually became a more sedate
player he eventually became a coach he's
coached the ukrainian women's team or
was coaching the ukrainian women's team
forever i mean just forever
um
uh and this one i think is one of his
better tournaments
this is the us ussr
championship played in minsk belarus uh
in 1987.
and this is really like iron gordon
speak even though he was technically
lower rated then
he was 25 45
but
25 45 in 1987 you were you were easily
top 40 top 50 in the world
and you were definitely invited to the
soviet championship and you were
definitely expected to do well well he
got third so he did they it all right
uh
hi tonya good to see you
uh somebody's asking me at what level
can players find bishop f5
um i'm actually gonna that's actually
such a good question i'm gonna go back
to it let me look at the position
see the question is not so easy to
answer because uh
if i gave this position to somebody and
told them
why to win
i would think that
a solid 2100 should be able to
guess that it's bishop f5 after some
thought because
there's really not that many
instead of moves it a study but when
you're looking in the game
you check it out
i don't want you
i'm not sure
yeah the love artist is pointing out
that in a real game it's different that
you get scared and it's not easy to give
up a bishop and i would think that this
combination only works if you see it
from afar so actually the question
becomes even doubly hard it's not just
do you see it during a game can you see
it
from this position
because you're gunning for something
right you're not just pushing your pawns
blindly at this level
and after f5
i think he saw this from afar
and i think you do have to be
a title player like i am maybe a very
strong fm
to have seen this from afar and say yeah
at this point i'm just winning
um and angoran is definitely above that
level so yeah yeah you expect this guy
to finish you off well that's a good
question right there's a lot of times
the computer just says oh bishop if i
was winning why didn't you see that
but it's hard right it's it's really
hard but i i always forget to say that
but if you guys have any questions at
any point feel free to raise your hand
or interrupt me
and
let me know if i need to go over
something sometimes i go very quickly
all right so this is this game against
kupaychik
um
and this is kind of a known game
even though
percent of the game is very
uninteresting
very uninteresting but it's worth it for
the final part so i want to skip
the most of it uh i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell you why this is a uh an
uninteresting game but basically we get
to this position
where black is pretty solid
and you see these double pawns they're a
little bit of a weakness but they're
hard to exploit i don't have a lot of
pieces that can attack them
and even though my bishop at night are
technically a bit better than that
bishop and the knight it's really not
they're not great pieces the knight
doesn't have e5 i don't know where i'm
going to go with my knight going back to
the structure analysis of the position
obviously obviously wipes better white
will be better for the rest of the game
because of this weaknesses on defile
but
when you play really strong players
sometimes they say yeah i have these
weaknesses
and
so
what's your point like what are you
going to do about it and it's not so
easy my rooks can't attack the pawns
nothing can attack the pawns you could
even put a chat of suggesting to put a
knight on f4 you could go go for it you
have all the time in the world to do so
and
uh they tried
after a few exchanges
we got this end game
and i think
a lot of grand masters
will look at this end game
look at the tournament they're in which
was i think a 22 rounder it's one it was
one of those tournaments that was like
16 to 20 or 22 rounds i forgot exactly
how many but it was a long tournament
you were allowed to take breaks
during tournaments you could you could
make a draw in seven moves this is good
old good old chess before the no draw
rules
but angry wasn't about that life
i know it's about
squeezing
something out of nothing
and here we go
i mean they danced and they danced and
they danced
and and they i mean
by the way whoever asked knight to f4
black ghost g5 eventually
yeah yeah you can see across the nest
triangulation he lost the tempo doesn't
actually mean anything
and they got all the way here
but
in spanish we call it
mariad to cause nausea on your opponent
then you just make what is seemingly the
same move forever
but it's not actually quite the same
move
and that at some point white goes to
move knight c6 in this position
and throughout
the entirety
of what we've been talking about
uh the move a6 was always available
and
it was apparently in most cases the
easiest way to equality
if you take on c6
uh you're actually not on time
yeah the king can go to e6 or whatever
but after the move
c7 this the skin can't actually approach
the pawn
yeah you just go bishop c6 and you're
completely stuck you actually get
zugswong at some point
uh if you had your power on a6 you could
go b5 but you don't
so
and if you take with the
uh knight
then you run the risk of actually losing
this bishop end game and i i think it's
lost
uh if you go back to 8 c7 is just
winning i go bishop d7 next move if you
go this way or or c8 it doesn't matter
then i start pressuring this weakness
and because there's no bishop on b7 no
you cannot defend it
now if the king was on e6 you could play
bishop b5
and take my pawn so if my king was on e6
bishop b5 take my bomb black's cool but
your king's not on e6
it's on f6
so you can't take
it's not easy to deal with this problem
but compression thought well no big deal
i'm just going to play a6 what's so what
right you can't take the pawn cause the
knights hanging
if you take on e7
uh i take only seven i think
takes takes bishop here
king e6 here here here and i have this
move and i just go back and forth
and it's a little scary but i think this
one was a draw
i have to go back on my notes and see it
but
it didn't quite work out for
for angler
so
we had already looked at this position
and compressed it asics and chilling
and after 97 i think he is
but he he severely underestimated this
move b takes a6
and
it turns out the black is in real
trouble here
um
if you take on a6
what does it happen if you take on a6
there was some problem with this uh i
think it was king before
and the second starts to become lost
it was night before
but there's anything lost
but the main point is why not take the
night
it's a little scary but
so what
it's a night i'm trying to win now
but the reason that angler was going
around and around and around and around
because he calculated the following
variation
and
it is just an amazing variation
so
off we go i cannot obviously i cannot
take on
uh here because i this king doesn't have
a way through
right i have to go king b3 and king a4
and the moment i go to a4 the knight
goes to a7 and i just protect
this is a well-known pattern
that
here
here everything is defended right
so this king doesn't make any progress i
can bring the king and take the pawn or
i can play g4 whatever black is winning
in this position
uh
we clearly didn't do this uh to do that
he actually played with king d4
and now if you trade
you're one tempo short
if this knight was on a7
black's winning actually the knight was
on c6 and move it 27 and swinging
but right now it's not it's actually the
opposite
because if the king penetrates
you're going to run out of squares for
this knight and guess what
second pawn
second pawn is going to be promoting
so black has no time to do that
but compression thought again
what's the big deal let me go back to a8
uh why not knight c6 to stop the
infiltration after king takes a4 that
you don't have time right the knights on
e7 not on
well oh the question is why not knight
c7 to stop the infiltration the answer
is it's illegal
that is the answer
so you don't have the time to do so but
the principles put the bishop back on a8
it says okay what's a big deal right
if you go king d5 for example
you're on time to play check
then i have to go b4 if you take on b6
takes and the bishop on c6 controls a8
and i will be more than on time to bring
my pieces i could also go a7 knight c8
eliminate one of the pawns that way it
doesn't really matter which way i do it
but that was not part of the plan king
d5 is not a plan the platinum which i
think is really cool
is this awesome
bishop d7 to me it was like a stake in
the heart
this bishop should not be on d7 this is
absolutely black controlled territory
but nobody's controlling it
and
this knight
is shockingly
dominated
right
can't move ca can go to doesn't do
anything on g6 it's on the way actually
i'd rather like not have the knight so i
can move the king to e7
but i can't
that's right because casual player says
the bishop on d7 not only cuts off the
knight it cuts off the king
do all purpose move
however
you don't get invited to the
soviet championship unless you're a
resourceful and cunning player which
coprachick definitely was so he says his
chance
he says check
king b5
and yeah if i move my knight i'm toast
because king takes b6
but
in chess i can also make my own threats
and black plays the clever move
f4
if you take twice d4 is hanging at the
end
and then we're talking about a mess this
pawn doesn't promote so easily and there
is a passport on d4
that still has to be accounted for
so if this happens i can do it the other
way around
if this end game happens
uh i believe the engine was saying that
white's not winning
i i don't remember if black is winning
or not but actually now that i look at
it
it's probably very easy
for the black side this one's not going
anywhere as long as there was a bishop
on aid and to remove the bishop from a8
i need to bring my king in but only one
of them can be at this at the time right
the king can only move the bishop away
or control c6 it cannot do both
and the moment i go chase that bishop
i'll go bishop c6 and i'll have enough
counterplay
but i'm gonna obviously have seen that
from advance you don't play bishop d7
and go into this variation without
expecting to move f4
and
after the move
uh bishop takes c6 what the players
calculated was this
cool
race where kratrick thought he was
winning
but he wasn't
because he saw bishop c6 looks
ridiculous of course if i take
and take and take
and he promotes
white
promotes first i don't have a way to
pick up the queen
but i don't really need to my queen is
better than yours my king is better than
yours your pawns are hanging
honestly this i think is winning queen
f8 here takes and then you pick up too
many too many puns
but even if i didn't have queen f8 uh
takes d6 i think the endgame is winning
but you have it so what's what's the
point of even calculating it
so
obviously black is not going to lose
tempe capturing the silly bishop
i'm just going to take immediately
and get my queen
anger said hi here's your queen enjoy it
he just allowed black to promote a queen
and it turns out
that this queen is actually totally
powerless
because of the exact placement of this
pawn on a3 preventing
queen b4 check
there is no good way
of preventing a7 a8
you have not one but two tempe to do it
and it's your move
but
black actually is busted
this actually reminded me
not the other way around i actually was
at a collegiate chess tournament
and i saw in a heavy time stop scramble
one of these players get a bishop on c6
and a pawn on asics
and i thought ah iron gorilla's game
and actually the setup if you analyze it
is really strong if you don't have a
perpetual chunk the queen can't do
anything
the queen cannot actually
extricate or force the king away from
the bishop the bishop always defends a8
and there are usually not enough checks
to prevent the pump from promoting
and here you just don't have any good
checks
you don't have any good checks at all
queen on b1
doesn't really help you i can still play
bishop b5 a7 next move then bishop c6
then then i'll hide the king where i
need to
for example something like
something like this
here
here here and you will very soon run out
of checks with the queen as powerful as
the queen is it it's not that powerful
for example check here check here that's
it
auto checks you got to let me promote
ah you got one more on it too but oh
yeah yeah sorry sorry but bishop b5 is
nice
because that's it there's no queen e8
there's no queen e8 because the bishop
controls it's kind of it's kind of like
a fantasy variation right it's one of
those things that you don't think
anybody is really going to play it you
see it in the studies
and it's a really cool concept in a
study
no but this guy played it
this guy actually sat down and played it
he's got guts and he was good
and i think that people that are able to
see and play even if it's just one game
like this they deserve to be on the
legends of chess on monday 7 30 at least
once
so
the game continued queen c3 but it's all
hopeless a3 he took a pawn
king b7 is precise
uh the move king a6 i think it does not
win
check king c7 now the king is completely
hidden thanks to this weakness
and after this a8
and takes takes king e5 black tried to
do his own thing
using his king but eingorn is just too
wise for that this is not even close to
working a very simple zugzwang
after bishop a6 the bishop's coming back
to d3
he gave up the pawn but
f4 is the easiest way to finish the game
no need to defend the bishop the pawn is
going to promote
first and uh anger won
an absolute brilliancy
and this is what i meant when like
90 of the game is really boring
because it's true right we don't even
remember how we got here really all we
know there were a couple of weaknesses
and eventually we got here but how cool
is that
that this move knight sees that he was
able to not just have the presence of
mind that he wasn't just moving around
but that there would be at some point
some moment
where because the king's on f6
exactly on f6
this never works with the king on
anywhere else actually the new bishop a
i think draws
there's actually i think no problem if i
remember correctly with the move bishop
aide
but he just thought the move king f6
looks nicer
and i think i remember correctly the
engines think that there's a way out for
black still
but who cares this is what he was
relying on
and it just doesn't work anymore
and i i think this is like such a
beautiful concept too to imagine
that you can dominate the queen
from all the way back
here even if he saw it here right
even if he saw it from this position
um when did he when did white see the
configuration of knight c6 and the
bishop d7 i actually do not know i wish
i had the information for that
unfortunately
a lot of these old soviet games
that you can find the annotations but
they're not as popular they're not as
popular as some of the better known
works so a lot of them have remained in
russian and i i just haven't gotten
around to asking somebody about it but i
am actually curious i'm gonna email
somebody that i know speaks russian see
if they have the tournament bulletin
of this because i have seen i have seen
the annotations obviously in english but
i don't think i've ever seen eingorn's
uh commentary on on when he saw it but i
don't care when he saw it ah people
translate google translate maybe that's
what i need to do i think they're like
actual physical books
translation work
he's from armenia uh yeah but they he
does speak russian uh the
who's teaching next door for those that
are in the chat
uh so i feel like bishop c6 it's really
cool
black's dominated
you you get to live a dream basically
even if it's just one chess game
the spanish they were in germans i don't
know where the german was but i think it
was somewhere before this mayhem
happened
it was before the mayhem happened
and uh
usually i think that there is another
german on move 60. so i wouldn't be
surprised that this was found in the
german but i don't care the thing is
they didn't have engines even coming up
with the concept is amazing
uh
yeah i thought it was really cool
so let me see how much time i have oh
it's a good time to stop um
so what did we learn today let's learn
about eingor
uh where's love eingorn
soviet chess player now represents
ukraine born in odessa
uh
hell of a player
it's one of those people that
i like to see their games even though
it's hard for amateurs to know them or
to remember them because there's so many
great players or there's so many there's
so much talent
in the chess world when sometimes you
imagine that somebody that sees all this
didn't even make it to the candidates
you kind of understand that chess is a
hard game
but they're
despite the fact that it's a hard game
there are so many brilliant minds and so
many great players that have been able
to sit down and grace us with the
brilliancy
and anger did this more than once i i
think this is his more
uh remarkable example uh both of these
two games but he has wins against
everybody he has wins against people
even even dating back to braunstein
uh he himself was a great player and
honestly i do not know if he is more
accomplished as a chess player or as a
coach because he has also taken
incredible talents
uh and turned him into real professional
chess players
as far as i know he's still coaching
i
have lost track of him a little bit i do
not know if he's currently living in
ukraine
yeah with the situation and everything
um but
i hope
he is not in ukraine right now
uh he has been such a
such a wonderful chess player kind of
from the sidelines from the shadows that
everybody knows he's there and he's
great and influential but you don't
sit and see his games that often so i
would like to it was fun for me to
spotlight
um
where is lafayer
no thank you guys for uh for joining i
think i'll i'll cut it here there's a
good stopping point
thank you appreciate it have a good
night guys and have a good night chat